the deutsche Comerford Omani Bremen and
conductor Pavo avi musical allies on a
mission to create a new Beethoven
they want their version of the Beethoven
symphonies to suit the 21st century they
call it the Beethoven project
and why another cycle who needs another
cycle we will always in need another
cycle Bremen in northern Germany from
here the door chicama Phantom Oni is
conquering the musical world
Pavel Yaffe has been the orchestra's
artistic director since 2004 and since
then almost anything seems possible
sold-out concerts resounding world tours
and acclaimed recordings the next
milestone performances of all nine
Beethoven symphonies at the Beethoven
fest embody when I met them and I heard
them play bet home and it became clear
that this this sounds how I wanted to
sound is that it took years until we
were able to produce a characteristic
sound quickly for Holly and Estella at
this point a different mood suddenly
comes in a fateful mood as I see it via
an Beethoven was a humanist he did not
compose only for a concert audience he
had a message for the whole of humanity
and his message is being heard around
the world the Beethoven project spells
success for the orchestra yeah I'm for
the Isaac on I did 30 years ago when
they started the prospects were not good
it was only going to happen if people
believed in the impossible movies but
not our views on how things should sound
in Beethoven's Infernus coincided and
the willingness to go deeper and find
the little details and obsess on every
detail which I love about this Orchestra
because they are obsessive like I am
the comma phenomena has arrived at the
Beethoven fest in Bonn one of Europe's
most renowned music festivals the
musicians are excited ahead of the first
concert their Beethoven marathon nine
symphonies in four days his beginning
to be able to actually prepare the nine
symphonies and I have physical stamina
to play all these big pieces in a row is
a major challenge
every piece has its own completely
different character so you have to be a
kind of an chameleon like an actor you
have to go from a classical Symphony to
more profound symphony go back to a
different character in the next symphony
and it requires a very quick ability to
adjust
and for musicians who are playing every
single note of it and and giving as much
from themselves as possible this kind of
adjustment is very difficult because you
are not only a machine who plays the
notes you get emotional involved
Beethoven was delivered with such
rhythmic ality and such drama and it's
at the same time with such rhetorical
precision
it was the symphonic sensation of this
year's festival that's a great review
there's not much time to relax the
musicians have to be in their places for
the morning dress rehearsal they're used
to the stress of concerts but this is a
little different here in Bonn the
Commerford hominy is not only performing
for the audience in the concert hall
Ordonez's it's not routine at something
special you begin to realize that
expectations are exceptionally high the
whole world will be able to look at the
DVD and the live cinema transmission
there's no safety net anymore
eight cameras are being used to film the
concerts certain passages are shot ahead
of time during the dress rehearsals
it's not only the musicians who are
being tested to the limits by this
Beethoven marathon their instruments to
have to deliver an extraordinary
performance
Frederika latsko has a problem with
their Italian viola concert master
florian don dava a company served the
workshop of stephan Pater greena
a bond violin maker many members of the
comical Romani have been his customers
for years be alarmed when you look at it
I stuck it with tape because it was a
splinter sticking out it's okay we can
deal with that let's suppose instrument
has been through a lot over the years it
was made in 1785 in a charity workshop
in the northern Italian city of cremona
oh I knew that wasn't a good idea when
you take a plaster off an open wound you
pull off the scab with it it's the same
here it's just this gap we're not
damaging the original van is just where
it's been touched up in the past it's
not a problem
grinder patches up the venerable
instrument with a little varnish and
great care ready for the next concert
it's a lot of family
it was great luck that I got this for
EULA and the moment I first paid a note
on it I was so moved by the sound since
then I've been in love with it but it's
also what I earn my living with I have a
practical attitude it's both things and
I like that
I am sorry it's the end of a long day
halfway through the Beethoven cycle
there's time to relax a little two
concerts done to still to come
the day was convinced it was very
special because somehow it becomes like
this just like a bigger picture
I love it
Oh bravo Bravo
in spite of the tight schedule the
musicians and the conductor do have some
free time between rehearsal and concert
a moment to gather strength for the
evening which each of them does in his
or her own way
hey listen I'm actually going to the
better Matt's house now so
Jesus that's efficient of being able to
unwind in between is extremely important
then you have the energy again in the
evening but we're all very different in
how we approach it everyone has their
own rhythm
of the bullets earlier on we were
discussing whether we were really going
to go for it tonight or whether we would
go for safety but of course we agreed we
would go for it as always we can't play
with the handbrake on a few streets away
in the center of Bonn the house where
Ludwig van Beethoven was born in 1770
today it's a museum and research centre
hello hello welcome a debate of
knowledge and fate of his birthplace the
Beethoven house holds the largest
collection of Beethoven materials
anywhere
museum director Michelin boga shows
poverty around the exhibition paintings
documents and instruments owned by
Beethoven give a glimpse into the life
of the composer things have certainly
developed I always struggled with an
idea that beth horon was actually a
human being because growing up in my
family most of Beethoven Brahms hiden
buff their gods
they were not humans and yet you have
a place where he was born here you have
all the things that put him back on
earth for you you see his manuscript you
see his handwriting
at the end of the day we've seen nothing
in arts can be really definitive
experience in performing arts because
even with the same text very often the
outcome of the performance is radically
different because the text is a starting
point it all has to do with choices
basically every every performer has to
make at the end his own or her own
choices
you
doesn't get better than this
with them
five years if tech wouldn't about to go
as long it will be performing the better
ones in Finnish they will always be
slightly different there is there's no
way of making an identical performance
it simply doesn't work that way
one of the things that I value most
about doing those cycles is that I feel
that the next one I've can be little bit
better because I've learned something
from one before and I feel that I know
how to do them better and I feel that
Orchestra and I have a closer
communication because we've been through
this process
the view is changing all the time the
view hasn't stopped changing the only
thing that we need to do is to keep up
to make sure that we that we are not
getting comfortable with all our sort of
successes but keep on looking for new
things keep on trying to see how far we
can go with the spaces and you know the
interesting part about doing a cycle
like this it tests your own emotional
and physical limit and once you learn
how to deal with though your limits you
can go further
inside the Beethoven haaa but also out
in the market square thoughts are
turning to the climax of the Beethoven
project the concert is being relayed to
an outside audience on a big screen in
total 6000 people will be able to hear
Beethoven's masterpiece
the comma phenomena is supported by the
Deutsche comic or and for soloists
I'm not necessarily sure that by just
listening to this music that better and
necessarily believed that all of the men
are brothers and I don't necessarily
think that he believed that all of those
great concepts are achievable
I almost feel that he knew that it isn't
the case but it was his hope that it
could be
I don't even know how to describe that
feeling because you have a feeling there
are so many layers and levels of how one
feels first of all you feel completely
exhausted but you also feel completely
elevated there is more adrenaline in
that room by the time the ninth symphony
is finished than anywhere else
you